last bit of uh commentary from trump's
rally in mendon illinois a mike pillow
the ceo of my pillow mike lindell known
to us as pillow of course we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines he spoke
and the crowd essentially
slept through him saying cnn is no
longer calling it the big lie
because it's all true
that the election was stolen from trump
in 2020 the crowd's totally bored by it
a cnn gets up getting out in front of
him and they said we were no longer call
it the big lie
because they know it was the big truth
and the big lie was the big lie
right donald trump won that election 81
or 82 million to biden's 66 million
those are the real totals everybody yeah
trump really won by what is that 14 16
16 million votes um this is a lie that
they're repeating that cnn no longer
calls it the big lie
because it's true that the election was
stolen from trump all that happened is
that there's been a shake-up in cnn
management and they've decided they want
to get away from the term the big lie
that nothing is changing about
the truth or in this case the falsity of
the claim that joe biden stole the
election from trump they've made an
editorial decision not to call it the
big lie nothing else has changed and
also a major major major announcement
from mike pillow he is now launching my
coffee but there's something funny about
it which doesn't sound very patriotic to
me take a listen to this but i'm
actually going to miami in three three
days or four days for filming for
filming filming we have my coffee this
is a family-owned coffee it's the best
coffee you're ever gonna have in your
life
there's nothing like it i believe me
everything that i put out there i do my
due diligence right i mean it's just
been six months in the work
works these guys have their own fields
in colombia
whoa wait a second they're in colombia
now i know many of you will say but hold
on a second david sir
most coffee beans are grown outside of
the united states for climate reasons
the united states is just not suited
climactically climatically clim i think
it's climactically to growing coffee
beans well okay but hawaii is
why isn't pillow doing the patriotic
thing and saying we will get
u.s raised coffee beans from hawaii no
he's offshoring it to colombia family
owned they've been doing it for years
imagine imagine a micro remember like a
microphone you know you can grind your
own or you can have you know a micron
field what the hell it's already ground
but having that where you can get it for
prices because that's what i do bring
the best to you right well it sounds
like the best isn't american mike uh
what what a situation and this guy will
not go away it's actually interesting
that
he's not fading at all and uh i don't
know what to make of it but the crowd
increasingly bored by mike pillow we'll
take a quick break back after this we
are going to hear some reactions
including from christy gnome governor of
south dakota to a great question okay so
you ban abortion
who funds all these children that women
are forced to carry the term she did not
have a good answer we'll look at it
after the break